so planes in these multi-dimensional
spaces how how difficult of an idea is
that to to come to do you think if you
if you look back in time yeah I think
mathematically it makes sense but I
don't know if it's intuitive for us to
imagine just what we're talking about
feels like calculus is easier to aisi
into it
well calculator I have to admit calculus
came earlier earlier than linear algebra
so Newton and Leibniz were the great men
to understand the key ideas of calculus
but linear algebra to me is like okay
it's the starting point cuz it's all
about flat things calculus has got all
the complications of calculus come from
the curves the bending this is a curved
surfaces linear algebra the surfaces are
all flat
nothing bends in linear algebra so it
should have come first but it didn't and
calculus also comes first in in high
school classes in in college class it'll
be freshman math I'll be calculus and
then I say enough of it like okay get to
get to the good stuff and that you think
linear algebra should come first
well it really yeah I'm okay with it not
coming first but it should yeah it
should it's simpler because everything
is flat yeah everything's flat of course
for that reason your calculus sort of
sticks to one dimension or so or
eventually you do multivariate but that
basically means two dimensions linear
algebra you take off into ten dimensions
no problem
it just feels scary and dangerous to go
beyond two dimensions well that's all if
everything is flat you can't go wrong
you